hé,
comment ça va,
je suis cool, je pensais que tu travaillerais sur
ton script, elle devait payer les factures,
comment vont tes affaires, tout va bien.
galactica chose qui se
passe après le 11 septembre ne peut pas croire que je viens de dépenser
dix-huit mille dollars allons dans la
camionnette c'est jerome salut il est si
ferme merveilleux Jérôme vient d'avoir une
audition pour battlestar galactica cisely
a blue matrix Je suis un grand fan  oh merci
bien euh bonne chance oh mon dieu azita Merci
Oh Sydney vient de me dire que tu étais là
j'étais dans le vestiaire je vais
t'appeler félicitations merci merci
je suis tellement excitée tu vas être une si bonne
chose toi '  Je vais adorer travailler avec
Damien ouais je suis super